Traductor: Rosa Rey
Revisor: Adrie Manquero
En este planeta en el que vivimos
existe un ser vivo
que supera y domina al resto.
Existen miles de millones de individuos,
y con su actividad, sin duda,
afectan de manera dramática
las vidas de todos los animales
y todos los seres vivos
que poblamos este planeta.
Hablo, sin duda, de las bacterias.
Están por toda la tierra:
están en la Antártida,
están en las profundidades marinas,
están en el bosque, están en este teatro,
están en tu piel, están en tu intestino,
están en el intestino de todos,
incluso en el intestino
de los astronautas.
Hay centenas y centenas
de diferentes especies de bacterias
y todas ellas viven
en una perfecta armonía
con el ambiente que colonizan.
Algunas veces, eventualmente,
las bacterias se lanzan a colonizar
un medio nuevo, un nuevo hábitat,
y de ello, el hombre consigue
generar un beneficio.
Algunas veces,
porque otras veces,
le causa un tremendo daño.
Estoy hablando de las infecciones.
Las infecciones ocurren cuando
una bacteria coloniza nuestro cuerpo.
La tuberculosis, por ejemplo.
La tuberculosis la causa la bacteria
Mycobacterium tuberculosis
cuando coloniza nuestros pulmones.
La bacteria crece, y obtiene
la comida que necesita para crecer
de nuestras células,
y destroza nuestros pulmones.
Veis, si os dais cuenta,
la bacteria no es un ser maligno,
lo único que quiere
es crecer, es sobrevivir.
El conflicto, el problema reside
en que nosotros somos la comida.
Las bacterias han causado la muerte
de millones y millones de personas
a lo largo de la historia de la humanidad,
y no hace falta retrotraerse
a la peste negra o a la lepra,
esas pandemias que causaron estragos
en el Medievo en Europa.
Basta solamente pensar
que en los años 20 ó 30,
contraer una infección de tuberculosis
era prácticamente una sentencia de muerte,
y la única posibilidad que existía
para paliar esa infección
era aislar a los infectados
en sanatorios en la sierra,
donde, por un lado, se protegía
a los no infectados de las ciudades,
y a la vez se proporcionaba a
los infectados sol, aire fresco, reposo,
para que estuviesen fuertes
y pudiesen combatir la infección.
Yo nací en un pueblo de Murcia
que se llama Alhama.
Es un pueblecito pequeño
que está a las faldas de Sierra Espuña.
En esa sierra está
este sanatorio de tuberculosos.
Afortunadamente, el sanatorio
está abandonado y amenaza ruina,
pero hubo un tiempo
en que era un punto muy activo
para recluir a enfermos de tuberculosis,
e intentar conseguir que se recuperaran,
con muy poco éxito, muy pocos
conseguían recuperarse de esta infección.
Hoy podemos abrir
una ventana en el tiempo,
podemos estar allí durante un instante,
porque alguien tomó esta fotografía
cuando el sanatorio estaba activo.
Fijaos qué cantidad de gente
y cuánta gente joven estaba sentada
en la terraza tomando el sol
esperando recuperarse de la tuberculosis,
ajenos, o quizá resignados,
a un más que posible fatal desenlace,
porque, como ya he dicho antes,
contraer una infección de tuberculosis
en aquellos tiempos
era prácticamente una sentencia de muerte.
Estos sanatorios,
al igual que otros muchos,
cerraron por falta de uso en los años 50.
Los antibióticos los borraron del mapa
en lo que fue uno de los
descubrimientos más importantes
de la historia de la humanidad.
Los antibióticos son moléculas
que producen las bacterias
para matar a otras bacterias
que compiten por colonizar el mismo nicho.
Pero el ser humano, gracias a su ingenio,
ha conseguido extraerlas y purificarlas,
y utilizarlas para su propio beneficio,
para curar infecciones.
Los antibióticos han supuesto
la revolución de la medicina
moderna del siglo XX,
porque gracias a ellos,
hemos conseguido ejecutar procesos
quirúrgicos extremadamente complejos
sin el peligro de contraer infecciones
durante el mismo o en postoperatoria.
Y aparte de eso, han ayudado sensiblemente
a erradicar las pandemias de la humanidad:
el tifus, el cólera, la lepra,
la tuberculosis, la gonorrea...
Sin embargo, a día de hoy,
se puede decir que los antibióticos
han sido víctimas de su propio éxito,
porque los hemos usado
de manera incorrecta, inadecuada,
hemos abusado de ellos.
Los hemos incluido en todas
las facetas de nuestra vida.
Los hemos utilizado
no solamente para curar infecciones,
sino para prevenir la posibilidad
de contraer infecciones.
Hemos generado pasta
de dientes con antibiótico,
crema para el acné con antibiótico,
pastillas para la tos con antibiótico,
antibiótico en la comida,
antibiótico en el agua,
antibiótico en los ríos,
en las granjas, en los animales,
antibiótico en todas partes
para protegernos
porque funcionaba muy bien.
Pero la vida siempre encuentra el camino,
y las bacterias se adaptan
porque quieren sobrevivir
como cualquier otro ser vivo,
y evolucionan, se convierten
en resistentes a los antibióticos.
Se llaman bacterias resistentes
o superbacterias, y son capaces de crecer
en los medios que nosotros les envenenamos
intencionalmente con antibióticos.
Y son la razón de que
en estas últimas décadas
haya habido un repunte muy significativo
en el número de infecciones.
Por poner un ejemplo cercano,
en España mueren 30 veces más personas
por infecciones de superbacterias
que por accidentes de tráfico.
Y si el problema se escala
de la manera en que lo está haciendo,
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
predice que en el año 2050
la infección por superbacterias
será la primera causa
de mortalidad en el mundo,
por encima de otras muchas
como es el cáncer,
o las enfermedades cardiovasculares.
"Pero dónde se encuentran estas
superbacterias que son tan peligrosas,
nunca he oído hablar de ellas",
os preguntaréis.
Los nichos que más nos preocupan
son aquellos en los que
el ser humano es vulnerable,
como por ejemplo los hospitales.
Los hospitales utilizan
muchos antibióticos, obviamente,
y las personas que están allí ingresadas
tienen las defensas bajas,
obviamente, porque están enfermos,
y eso a la vez los hace susceptibles
de ser infectados
por bacterias resistentes.
Las infecciones de los hospitales
están causando
que procesos quirúrgicos
relativamente sencillos
ahora resulten muy complejos
y muy difíciles de llevar a cabo
porque existe un riesgo muy serio
de contraer una infección que complique
la recuperación del paciente,
desemboque en una infección crónica,
o incluso llegue a causar la muerte.
Dejadme que os presente hoy
a la protagonista de la historia:
esta bacteria que os enseño aquí
es el Staphylococcus aureus,
resistente a las penicilinas.
Es una bacteria muy típica
en los hospitales,
causa la mayoría de las infecciones
de los hospitales.
Aquí en la foto no parece muy peligrosa,
de hecho, parece como un racimo de uvas.
Su nombre Staphylococcus viene del griego,
que significa exactamente eso:
racimo de uvas.
Es una bacteria que se encuentra
de manera natural en nuestra piel
y en nuestras fosas nasales,
y todos la tenemos,
y ahí, en ese hábitat, no es patógena,
incluso nos ayuda, nos previene
de contraer infecciones por hongos.
El problema reside cuando
se rompe la barrera de la piel,
por una operación quirúrgica o un bisturí,
un catéter o una simple inyección
que podría internalizar Staphylococcus
aureus en nuestro cuerpo
y generar una infección.
Si nos infecta en el hueso
generará una osteomielitis;
si coloniza los pulmones
generará una neumonía;
si coloniza el cuerpo entero
generará una sepsis general.
Y todas esas infecciones
serán muy difíciles de tratar
si la cepa que nos ha infectado
es resistente a los antibióticos.
¿Qué se puede hacer para combatir
a estas superbacterias?
¿Qué medios tenemos?
Existen muchísimos laboratorios
en el mundo entero cuyo objetivo
es entender cómo las bacterias
evolucionan su resistencia a antibióticos
y cómo se puede desarrollar una nueva
estrategia de combate para vencerlas.
Yo dirijo uno de esos laboratorios,
aquí en Madrid,
y trabajamos con el Staphylococcus aureus
resistente a la penicilina.
Hasta ahora sabíamos
que el Staphylococcus aureus
genera esa resistencia a los antibióticos
mediante un complejo proteico
que es como el motor de un coche.
Tiene varios componentes
y necesita ensamblarse todo
para poder funcionar el motor
y que le proteja, que le sirva como coraza
frente al martillo,
que son los antibióticos.
El ensamblaje del complejo proteico,
el ensamblaje de ese motor,
hemos descubierto que ocurre
en zonas muy concretas
de la superficie de la bacteria.
Hemos descubierto que la superficie
de la bacteria no es regular,
es heterogénea, tiene diversas zonas
de diferente composición,
como si fuese la piel de una vaca,
con manchas blancas y negras,
y el complejo proteico
tiene que localizarse
en una de esas zonas concretas,
en las manchas negras, digamos,
para poder ensamblarse
correctamente y ser funcional.
A partir de ahí, utilizando
la biología molecular,
hemos conseguido manipular
el ADN de la bacteria;
hemos generado un mutante
que tiene la superficie de la bacteria
mucho más homogénea, mucho más regular,
y hemos visto que en ese mutante
el complejo proteico no se ensambla
correctamente porque no encuentra su sitio
y lo que ocasiona es que
una superbacteria deje de serlo
y se convierta en
una bacteria convencional
que podemos eliminar comúnmente
con los antibióticos de toda la vida.
A partir de ahí, la biología molecular
nos enseña el camino,
decide cuál es la estrategia de combate.
Nuestra estrategia de combate
es generar una bacteria
que sea homogénea en su superficie
para que el complejo no se ensamble.
Hemos utilizado compuestos
que, añadidos a los cultivos,
inhiben la producción de una cierta grasa
de la superficie de la bacteria,
que hace que se deforme la superficie
y se convierta en más homogénea.
Dicho de otra manera:
estos compuestos, al ponerlos
en presencia de la bacteria,
hacen que la piel de la vaca no tenga
manchas blancas y negras,
sino que sea una vaca
completamente blanca.
En ese momento, en presencia
de esos compuestos,
el complejo proteico, ese motor,
no se puede ensamblar correctamente
y pierde su funcionalidad.
Lo interesante es que muchos
de esos complejos son las estatinas,
son las moléculas que utilizamos
para bajar el colesterol
en los pacientes con hipercolesterolemia,
que tienen el colesterol alto.
Estoy seguro que mucha gente
en este auditorio está tomando estatinas,
se pueden preguntar cuánto tiempo hace
que no contraen una infección.
Una combinación
de estatinas con antibióticos,
vemos que es capaz de matar
a cepas resistentes a los antibióticos
que comúnmente no teníamos ninguna
estrategia de cómo hacerlo.
Y otro aspecto muy importante
de este trabajo
es que tenemos la esperanza
de poder volver a reciclar
antibióticos que habían caído en desuso,
estaban totalmente desahuciados,
porque la resistencia
a antibióticos de las bacterias
los había convertido en inútiles.
Podemos incrementar nuestro arsenal
porque las estatinas desarman los
complejos de resistencia a antibióticos,
y una vez que están desarmados,
podemos matar a las bacterias
con antibióticos convencionales.
Hemos desarrollado
nuestros experimentos en ratones,
están generando resultados espectaculares,
tenemos la esperanza que en un futuro
se puedan convertir en una terapia
que le sirva al ser humano para defenderse
de las superbacterias en los hospitales.
Pero esto solo es una batalla ganada
en una guerra que no tiene fin,
porque como he dicho anteriormente,
la vida siempre encuentra el camino,
y la bacteria se adaptará
porque tiene que sobrevivir
y seguro que encuentra una vía
para evitar este tratamiento.
Nosotros tenemos que evolucionar con ella,
y generar cada vez
procedimientos más complejos
que nos permitan seguir luchando
contra las superbacterias.
Todos juntos:
los hospitales, los médicos,
los centros de investigación
y nosotros desde nuestras casas,
con pequeños gestos,
podemos contribuir enormemente
a frenar a las superbacterias.
Con pequeños gestos, por ejemplo:
Usad los antibióticos solamente
si los prescribe el médico,
porque puede ser que la infección
que tengamos no sea bacteriana,
en ese caso los antibióticos no tienen
ninguna funcionalidad.
Cuando nos los prescribe el médico,
debemos terminar el tratamiento,
aunque nos sintamos bien el primer día,
tenemos que continuar hasta el final,
porque cerrar el tratamiento antes,
hace que el tratamiento sea más débil
y aumente las posibilidades
de desarrollar superbacterias.
Cuando hayamos terminado el tratamiento
no podemos tirar los antibióticos
ni a la basura ni al inodoro
porque van a parar al medioambiente,
a los ríos y al suelo,
y allí también hay bacterias
que desarrollarán superresistencia.
Tenemos que tener cuidado
y ser conscientes
de que conlleva un cierto riesgo
someterse a operaciones quirúrgicas,
solamente tenemos que someternos
a ellas si es necesario.
Y por último, lavarnos bien las manos
y cocinar bien los alimentos,
para protegernos.
Con todos estos gestos,
y con la ayuda de los hospitales
y de los laboratorios de investigación,
son las únicas herramientas que tenemos
para continuar en la carrera
con las bacterias
para ganarles esta batalla.
Porque cada vez que las bacterias
nos han adelantado en esta carrera
hemos estado indefensos ante ellas,
y estas últimas décadas
que hemos estado adelantados,
que hemos estado en ventaja,
han sido las décadas más saludables
de la historia de la humanidad.
Debemos proteger esa ventaja,
debemos gestionar bien nuestros recursos
que tanto trabajo y tanto esfuerzo
nos ha costado conseguir.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)